ah Carlos Eduardo da Silva debate
impresionantes estos primeros
declaraciones de los tres cursos despectivos
intelecto Hola brasileños un discurso
anthony allí unidad
indicador
brasileños y
multipuntos, analizando este
es tu opinión
de Brasil Vogue allí Ingreso global como Ah
un país, etc. país que buscará ejercer
liderando efectivamente o liderando por
El líder regional es
grupo de países que integran es sordo
global y un discurso
donde Lula demuestra que es muy
consciente de que cambiar por el
La sociedad brasileña no es precisamente
romo a una armonía alrededor de la
la democracia es muy importante
impulsar las fuerzas productivas de nuestros
sociedad muy importante para impulsar
inmovilizados por la capacidad productiva de
nuestros trabajadores Así que estos son muchos
importante entender un proyecto y un
proyecto
no asociado Lula abla por ejemplo
para desarrollar nuestra industria
retomar el reto de nuestra industria y
señalando la necesidad de que esto sea
ambos productores de conocimiento de
consejo
y dulces se trata de recuperar papel de
la ciencia que fue destruida gobierno
bolsonaro
se trata de recuperar esto liderando el
intelecto científico Porque existe el
que nos permitirá enfrentar y superar
su misticismo se enfrenta y se supera
irracionalismo
oh, eso realmente resume esto
capacidad conjunta de la sociedad
brasileño en torno a un proyecto de
desamor que medicina
es bueno es nuestro sordo porque eso es lo que
ella justo destruyó fue
el dibujo es un pantano que
se desvaneció por completo tu habilidad
de autoorganización y desmantelada
plenamente su capacidad cultural
es en esa cadena lo que en 2012/2013
tendríamos grandes movilizaciones sociales
guías de patas muy progresivas que
incluso buscó ampliar la Constitución
de 1988 que estaban en la Constitución de
derechos y era exactamente igual a la
período 1016 que impulsa esta enmienda
constitucional 95 porque con ella logato
público es primario entonces
incluso porque fue su error
segundo período
Fue este error el que permitió
que ella ya creó ofensiva porque
allí desde la lausteridad
Me confundí muy grande en La Cabeça
por población
de la izquierda a la apropiada por el
Recursos viales para que estés allí
mostrar que el estado puede ser un error
de brasileño desbolho parece que
es un punto claro
esta búsqueda es para mostrar cómo un más
la tecnologia se llama
relación
específico de la economía es muy
rentable impresionante coronaria a
nivel internacional
Lo importante en la economía muy grande
al tan llamado nector
significativo